[Música]
Rusia permanece de luto este sábado
jornada en la que se desarrolló el
funeral de bladetsky El popular bloguero
prorruso que murió en una explosión en
una cafetería de San Petersburgo el
domingo pasado
tatavski fue despedido en un cementerio
de Moscú con un robusto operativo de
seguridad rodeado múltiples honores
militares y con una presencia
distinguida la del líder del grupo
Wagner y Eugenio y pregosin
para un sector de la política rusa el
periodista se transformó en un símbolo
nacionalista
siempre dijo lo que pensaba su vida fue
brillante fue verdadera fue es y será un
ejemplo para esos jóvenes que hoy viven
por Rusia donde personas de diferentes
puntos de vista están unidas incluso
personas de la oposición se mantienen
unidas por el país por su futuro por el
presidente
a su funeral también concurrieron
excompañeros militares que combatieron
junto a él en las fuerzas separatista
del nopaz donde prestó servicio Como
voluntario hace casi una década
tengo muchos amigos cercanos con el
difunto somos milicianos de la primera
ola no quedamos muchos él como yo se
metió en este movimiento en 2014
el presunto asesinato de tatasky
encendió una alarma en los civiles rusos
que temen que el conflicto avance sobre
el país
la guerra por la supervivencia continúa
han decidido destruirnos a todos Es
simplemente una cuestión de tiempo aquí
los misiles también vendrán ya están
llegando
por la investigación de la muerte del
periodista las fuerzas de seguridad
detuvieron al área trepova la mujer de
26 años que le dio la estatuilla con
explosivos y fue arrestada bajo delitos
de terrorismo desde
Moscú le achacaron la organización del
ataque a la inteligencia ucraniana una
acusación rechazada desde que